like Albert Einstein says don't try and
be successful trying to be valuable the
only way you'll become successful is by
being valuable what characteristics you
have someone entrepreneurial
entrepreneurial someone that's not
thinking like a nine to fiver if you're
watching the clock thinking about five
o'clock I'm out of here that's not an
entrepreneur that's not an intrapreneur
that's that's an employee mindset
whereas if you're thinking I don't work
9:00 to 5:00 I like to start to finish I
just get I I'm thinking about the
results I'm thinking about the tasks and
I'm owning it get quite big on everyone
being intrapreneurial yeah so basically
definition of an intrapreneur according
to Samuel Leeds is I don't know if it's
a term that's used a lot but is an
entrepreneur but from within a company
so most most entrepreneurs fail
statistically 80% of businesses fail and
the other 20% that apparently succeed
they don't succeed because most of them
that make any money anyway they just
don't get closed down so so to be an
entrepreneur is lonely is risky is hard
it's high-pressure anyone that solving
problems is really an entrepreneur
because most people either avoid
problems yeah or find problems you know
they'll focus in on the problem whereas
I want to be someone and surrounded by
people who are instead of doing that who
are constantly finding solutions all
there's a problem here we've got this
issue you know we haven't got a big
enough venue or this property we can't
get planning permission for this
property okay how can we get around this
who can we speak to who can we I think
that's the definition of an entrepreneur
so what I'm looking for is to find
people who are natural born
entrepreneurs leaders innovators inspire
us and then have them with inside the
company so they then they become
intrapreneurs and they bring their skill
set their creativity their passion their
drive their ambition their intrapreneurs
with with that a part of the mission
energy means big results
and have fun while you working and enjoy
what you're doing because I know I'm
enjoying what I'm doing and I'll be
damned if I know that people are working
within the company that there's no
perfect business there's no perfect
system there's no perfect company we're
certainly not perfect I'm certainly not
perfect but that's that's only what I
believe so do you think that anybody can
be an entrepreneur like do you think
it's something that you can develop no I
don't think anyone can be an
entrepreneur I guess anyone can try I
mean entrepreneur cannot be successful I
guess without the correct training
without the support without the without
the desire without the imprinted natural
burning desire to do it I mean I I don't
know I'm talking about someone that
wants to go and make millions of pounds
have loads of staff we're in a really
big enterprise that's kind of what I'm
talking about when I'm saying you gotta
have a deep burning desire because
there's gonna be a lot of crap you have
to go through to get to that so people
that become financially free some of
them have got the desire in the burn and
then I'll be like hey you need a mission
so what advice would I give to be a very
serious entrepreneur you've got to have
the fire in your belly you've got to
have the burn some people have the fire
in the belly they have the burn but then
people dampen air and because of fear
and lack of support and lack of training
it doesn't come to anything and then
these people they know on their you know
in their retirement saying I wish I wish
I'd done this I could have done this I
had the capability to do this yeah but
you didn't you chickened out so I don't
say is if you've got the fire then just
do it and get the support and take the
risk if you haven't got the fire and you
don't want to do it no that's fine I
think attitude is more important skill
so if someone's got really good skills
but they've got not a great attitude
yeah
they don't love the company they don't
love what they're doing then in my
opinion in my book that would not be
someone that I would want to hire
everybody is born with a desire to do
something some people
desire to want to be dancers or singers
or performers or investors or I was born
with a desire to run a business and help
people and when I say help me be because
and some people think that it's like
almost like oh well I run a business and
make lots of money but I do help people
too as if the to a contrary but actually
if you're running a successful business
by definition you're helping a lot of
people if you do it because it's cool
you know I it's cool and I watched a few
Gary Vaynerchuk videos and and and yeah
then you're gonna if you do it as a
Seidel so you get a guess I post results
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]